من موسكو ومراسل
امازن عباس اهلا بك مازن نتوقف معك بدايه
عند هذه الزياره التي يجريها وزير
الخارجيه الصيني وهذا اللقاء مع نظيره
الروسيه
وايضا قد يكون هناك ربما لقاء مع الرئيس
بوتين نفسه مدى عن هذه الزياره وهل من
مؤشرات على ما ستتضمنه اجنده هذا اللقاء
الاوساط المقربه من الدبلوماسيه الروسيه
هذه الزياره بالدرجه الاولى تستهدف
الاعداد لقمه روسيه صينيه يفترض ان تنعقد
في موسكو ربيع هذا العام وهذه القمه تتضمن
بنود اساسيه على مستوى الشراكه او التحالف
الاستراتيجي بين بكين وموسكو وبالتالي
هناك عدد من الاتفاقات التي يتم او تتم
مناقشتها وايضا تحضير
لاوراق عمل مشتركه
لذلك من المتوقع بالفعل ان يلتقي المسؤول
الصيني مع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
في هذا السياق الى ان هذه الزياره بحسب
خبراء روس هي لن تتضمن قرارات او تفاهمات
محدده وانما تتركز على اعداد الارضيه لذلك